diez mil soldados rusos cientos de
tanques y decenas de aviones y buques de
guerra entrenando en la frontera
ucraniana estás imágenes de abril han
dejado su huella en la mente de los
países de la otan el jueves la alianza
atlántica adoptó una nueva estrategia
enteramente dedicada a la defensa contra
rusia
no vamos a imitar el comportamiento
desestabilizador de rusia y no tenemos
intención de desplegar nuevos misiles
nucleares en suelo europeo
por ello estamos reforzando un paquete
de medidas políticas y militares para
responder a esta amenaza tres puntos el
escenario que la otan prevé en su nuevo
plan un ataque simultáneo de rusia en
las regiones del báltico y el mar negro
potencialmente con armas prototípicas
nucleares ataques informáticos y ataques
desde el espacio para preparar su
defensa la alianza cuenta con un fondo
de mil millones de dólares se utilizará
para financiar la innovación y la
modernización de su arsenal mientras los
estados miembros están alarmados por las
últimas tecnologías militares rusas como
un misil hipersónico o robots de combate
desplegados hace unas semanas durante
los ejercicios contra bielorrusia sin
embargo la alianza especifica que no
espera un ataque inminente de rusia y
apelamos
a la otan debe seguir haciendo lo que ha
hecho hasta ahora prepararse la mano del
audaz y entendida rusia debe
aprovecharla
rusia por su parte ni a cualquier
hostilidad hacia los países europeos y
considera que es la otan la que corre el
riesgo de desestabilizar el continente
con estos preparativos